>> BASICALLY THERE AREAS OF
NEW YORK WHERE PEOPLE FEEL THE
STREETS HAVE BEEN SURRENDERED
THE LIST GOES ON TO SOMEONE
WHO HAS BEEN ATTACKED AT THE
SUBWAY STATION BATTLING HER
VISION THE PERSON WHO ATTACKED
HER JUST VIOLATED PAROLE AND
WAS RELEASED FOR ONCE
MURDERING HIS OWN
GRANDPARENTS.
THAT'S NOT JUST THE LAST YEAR
OR TWO WE'RE TALKING THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
STEVE: THAT WAS EARLIER
TONIGHT FROM THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW YORK TALKING ABOUT THE
SHOOTING THAT HAPPENED RIGHT
OUTSIDE HIS HOME.
HE IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
EVERYWHERE THIS CRIME RATE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY OR NEW YORK
STATE ARE THOSE INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA.
THE OTHER WEEK I WENT DOWN TO
VENICE BEACH BUT GUESS WHAT I
FOUND MYSELF QUICK.
>> YOU KNOW THAT QUESTION
EVERYONE WAS ASKING FOR SO
LONG WHERE IS HUNTER?
IF YOU WOULD COME HERE ARE
WHILE AGO THE ANSWER WOULD
HAVE BEEN THERE.
THEY ARE.
HUNTER BIDEN MANSION IN
VENICE.
ON THE CANAL.
A LOVELY PLACE HUNTER BIDEN
RESIDED THERE.
$25000 A MONTH.
A BEAUTIFUL HOUSE.
I THINK NOW THEY PAINTED IT.
USED TO BE WHITE IT ATTRACTED
A LOT OF ATTENTION.
LOOK OVER THERE.
NOW THOSE TENANTS HAVE MOVED
THEY HAVE BEEN MOVED FROM THE
BEACH WHERE THE MEDIA
ATTENTION AND THEN CLEANED IT
UP BUT WHEN HUNTER LIVED THERE
THERE WAS NOBODY IT WAS SECRET
SERVICE.
THAT'S HOW IT GOES IF YOU ARE
HUNTER BIDEN.
LOOKS LIKE HE GOT OUT JUST IN
TIME BECAUSE A FEW DAYS THE
HOUSE RIGHT THERE ON THE CANAL
WAS BURNED DOWN BY HOMELESS
PEOPLE WHICH IT TURNS OUT IS
NOT JUST A NORMAL PART OF LIFE.
THE L.A. TIMES REPORTED OVER
HALF, 54 PERCENT OF ALL FIRES
IN THE L.A. FDR RELATED TO
HOMELESSNESS.
BE CLEAR THE CHAOS AND CRIME
NOW INFLICTED ON PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN THE GREAT CITIES SO
THAT AS THE FILTH AND THE
SQUALOR AND TH